-It is time to settle
some of the biggest
and most important debates
of all time,
but I'm gonna need some help.
Season 3 of his show,
"After Life,"
is available now on Netflix.
Please welcome the one,
the only Ricky Gervais!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow, one of my favorites, Ricky!
Ricky, it's nice to see you.
Are you ready to do this?
-What is it this time?
-Yeah.
You don't like playing the games
on our show as much.
-The pressure is on, isn't it?
-No, no pressure.
This game you're gonna love.
This one is called
"Ricky Gervais Settles It."
-♪ Ricky Gervais settles ♪
♪ Ricky Gervais settles it ♪
-So you're the only person
that can play this.
We've put your name
in the title of the game.
Yeah.
-Yeah, it's great. I love that.
-Alright, so, here we go.
First up. Ready?
Should you take videos
during concerts?
-No. Just watch the --
You've gone to see someone live.
Watch it live.
-Exactly right.
Good man.
Oh -- oh, my goodness.
Who was the best James Bond?
-Well, my first thought was
Sean Connery.
-Yeah.
-I don't --
I'm not a big fan of Bond.
I've only watched a couple.
I like Sean Connery
because -- I don't know why.
I liked him in "The Rock,"
as well.
Yeah, it's all of that putting
on suits and dry martinis.
I don't look good in a suit.
I don't aspire to be --
I look -- I look rubbish in
everything, so, you know,
I'd like him in a tracksuit
and stained T-shirt
or something.
-So you can't relate to
James Bond.
You can't relate to James Bond.
-Yeah, no.
-Next question -- text or call?
-Depends.
-Well, how about,
like, those audio texts?
-No, I can't --
No, because I'll leave it on,
and then I'll start slagging
the person off.
And then they'd just get
a message of me going,
"Oh, he's a [bleep] idiot."
I'm very nervous about this
and microphones and stuff
that I just --
Text is safe for us folks.
-Ricky, what is scarier?
Space or the ocean?
-Well, it depends.
If you're in a boat, space would
be a lot scarier, wouldn't it?
Whereas if you're
having a gentle row,
then space
would be really scary.
If you're shooting through space
at 500 miles a second
with no oxygen, then --
I think space, in general,
is a bit scary, because it's --
Yeah, it's, like, you know,
miles and miles of nothing.
At least with the ocean,
you think you might
see a lighthouse or
a dolphin might save you,
that like, you only --
You never know.
Flipper might come along.
-Yes, Flipper.
-But what if
you're waiting for Flipper,
and it goes along and he goes...
[ Clicks tongue ]
And you go, "Brilliant!
Save me."
But you've met
the one mean dolphin.
You've met, like,
the Charles Manson of dolphins.
And he just goes,
"No, you've picked the wrong
dolphin, buddy."
I think space is scarier.
-Alright, well, not with
those types of dolphins.
Alright, ready for this?
Who was the best Beatle?
-Well, I'm gonna say one of
the ones that are alive
in case they're watching.
-Come on.
You can be honest with me.
-Well, Paul McCartney.
I saw that documentary,
and he seemed to be
sort of running the show.
So, I mean, listen,
they're all great, but --
Yeah, Paul McCartney
because he did the frog song.
I like that frog song he did.
-Yeah, I love that song, too.
Yeah, I like that song.
I know exactly -- Alright,
if you had to be a cannibal,
who would you eat?
-Well, I'm vegan,
so it's even worse for me.
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-So I wouldn't --
-Why not Paul McCartney?
He's vegan.
-Well, it doesn't
make any difference
if you eat someone who's vegan.
You're still eating meat,
aren't you?
If you eat a cow,
that doesn't make you vegan
'cause you're eating
an animal that's vegan.
-So you wouldn't eat
Paul McCartney
even if you had the chance.
-Well, I'd rather not
eat anyone.
I have to say --
-I can't believe it.
Paul, he's a legend.
He's one of the best -- He's the
best performers of all time.
-I know that! He's not --
-You would step over his body --
-That's how you pay tribute to
your heroes, is it?
You go, "Oh, you're so good.
You're so good,
I could eat a finger."
Where would you start?
Where would you start
if you had to be --
That's how I want to go,
I think.
I just want to be fed
to the lions in London Zoo.
Just thrown in naked
when I'm dead.
And then just watch people go,
"Is that the bloke from
'The Office'?
He's just being eaten by lions."
-Last one, last question.
British or American "Office"?
-Well, I thought the British
"Office" was the best,
but my accountant assures me
that it's the American version.
-That's the exact answer.
You heard it here first.
My thanks to Ricky Gervais!
We're talking to Ricky more
after the break.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]